before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
the doctor at our medical facility this
always goes well
[Music]
hey there folks
we are now up to
the saranga conundrum
man this episode's weird
not in like a very interesting way not
like in a bizarre ooh strange new ideas
way but just in a
how'd this end up like this kind of way
and like here's the thing saranga
conundrum is a very maligned episode and
i'm not going to say
wrongly
but honestly
it's a little too dull for me to get
worked up about that's not to say i
won't get worked up over the course of
talking about it i might i'm me
but at the same time like ultimately the
things that are wrong with it are very
pedestrian problems
they're uninteresting problems
as much as i
low
the
something like hell bent its problems
are interesting to talk about because
they're pretty unique problems
something like this it's it's just an
undercooked script
there really isn't anything at the
fundamental core
of the story as a whole or any of the
main concepts at play that would never
have worked or like why would you do
that it's more a case of okay
i get what you're going for but this
just isn't clicking
it just feels like a failure of
polish
it feels like a script that desperately
needed at least one more cleanup pass
and like here's the thing i'm finding
myself thinking more and more and more
every time i see one of these episodes
especially the ones that chibnall
himself scripted
i'm finding myself really dwelling on
the writing
because
as i've noted elsewhere show looks good
most of the performances are good none
of the performances in the in this
episode are bad some of them are really
good actually i'll even highlight some
of that
but the writing is where things just are
falling down
and this is another one that feels like
this feels like bullet point writing i
can see how this as a script outline
could result in a good episode in terms
of doctoring companions on a medical
ship with minimal crew largely automated
problem happens on board there are other
people on board as well but they're all
patients having their own issues so
you've got to deal with with that at the
same time as dealing with whatever is
the actual threat to the ship
you're on a ticking clock because if it
is believed by the place you are going
to that the ship is somehow contaminated
and shouldn't and is a danger to be let
on board they're going to blow the ship
up like
the these as a series of bullet points
as an episode outline
rough script
where you're not actually laying out
every scene but just saying okay this
scene
this happens this scene somebody says
something that amounts to this
this probably had a really solid outline
but the final product is very little
more than just that outline in those
bullet points
again with characters just
doing whatever the bare minimum is
for them to fulfill whatever the outline
said happened in this scene and then we
move on
again there's a couple of exceptions to
that some even good exceptions but
that's just the general vibe i get
coming off this and again i'm feeling
like certain things were reverse
engineered by story necessity the peting
the alien feels like a really good
example of that first of all um the
patang
really
i mean okay look the name
i don't want to harp on this too much
but chipmunk really sucks
at coming up with alien names it's going
to come up again
across this series especially
but like you're really going to name
something that is threatening the entire
ship after what sounds like an
onomatopoeia sound effect from a comic
book of a bullet ricocheting off a metal
plate
[Music]
that's what that's what we're calling
this
okay i remember my first review sort of
harping on the fact that like the
musical build up and the visual framing
of this thing doesn't match how cute it
is
and like that's not inherently a problem
you could play off the fact that it is
cute despite the fact that it is
dangerous but nothing in the script
actually plays off that i tried to look
up to see if i could find like early
concept drawing see if it was always
supposed to be this cute but i i didn't
have a lot of luck finding that or at
least anything that i could be certain
was in fact legit and not like
somebody's fan art that they claimed was
concept art um so i i don't know if this
is the case but it feels like earlier
conception the conception during say the
shooting period of it was to have it not
be this cute because nothing about the
shooting the music or the character
reactions plays off the fact that it's
cute and again in and of itself the fact
that it looks cute is not a problem
it's just it's a really weird thing to
have completely unacknowledged given the
way it behaves and how it functions in
the story it's odd and it's another
thing that just seems somewhat
undercooked and it would make more sense
to me
if the creature was either redesigned or
the design was fully locked down in
post-production while they were doing
the effects work and it became cuter
than anybody else involved at any point
in the shoot expected it to be but at
that point it was too late to reshoot
everything maybe it's an offshoot of how
small it is like they definitely knew it
was going to be this small you can tell
that from the shooting and the eye line
angles and everything else so maybe in
the
creation of it they thought well if it's
gonna be the small we can't really make
it scary let's just lean into being cute
i'm speculating too much about this
though it just like i don't like the
tang
i don't think it works very well and
so some of the interactions i'm just
kind of gonna work through this thing at
this point
um
the opening
is not great the cold open on the junk
planet which i had completely forgotten
was a thing
it's not good
not so much that it's bad in and of
itself the general idea of the doctor
and the companions you know just looking
for parts in a scrap yard there's
nothing wrong with that that's fine
what the problem is is in context to how
few adventures they've had so far and
the kind of stuff that keeps happening
what i mean by that is
they come across a sonic mine
in other words the doctor
carelessly put them in danger and then
failed to get them out of it because the
mind goes off and they are
coincidentally miraculously saved by a
passing medical vessel
this is the exact same solution that
happened when they were floating in
space at the end of the very first
episode the doctor screwed up
put them in danger by being reckless and
careless but then
miraculously they're just safe from that
situation which means
nobody ever confronts the doctor with
the fact that she's putting them in this
kind of danger because here's the thing
it's okay
if this doctor is reckless and is making
mistakes and screwing up but you have to
actually do something with that fact
what's happening instead is she's just
making really stupid errors in judgment
and doing things that should get not
only her but these three other people
killed and then just miraculously
doesn't
and so she doesn't learn she doesn't
change nobody brings it up nobody
addresses it nobody confronts her with
this
and that's where it becomes a problem
it's okay if the doctor
is not perfect the doctor honestly
shouldn't be perfect but the ways in
which the doctor is imperfect
should factor into things
and having it result in situations that
just they get miraculously saved from
that and that just happens to put them
in the next adventure scenario
is really really lazy
that's lazy that's sue that's such lazy
writing
it just is i'm sorry i don't like to
call other writers lazy because writing
is hard it's really hard
i know that
but come on
now that having been said once we get
past that cold open the first 15 minutes
of this episode
are actually really solid like there's
that cold open hiccup and there's like a
weird quirk that like i'm realizing now
going back because i've seen so i've
seen more than a few people and i'm
gonna keep an eye on this
catch the fact that and i even noticed
myself a bit in rosa that whenever the
doctor runs into a historical figure she
basically just
word vomits out their wikipedia entry
like the major points and what's
important about them
what's kind of interesting
is she does it here too
with a fictional future space general
you're mentioned in the book of
celebrants you helped defeat the army of
the eons at the back of the undercut i'm
not gonna say that that makes it okay
that she does that it's still like it's
still awkwardly delivered crowbard in
exposition
but there is a consistency to it she
does it with people who aren't real too
so for whatever that's worth but like
again i know i'm complaining but
honestly the first 15 minutes are solid
we meet all the various characters
involved we meet astros the other doctor
we meet the medical assistant we meet
the general the general's android
assistant her brother the guy who's
pregnant and all of this these
introductions are are mostly well him
they're either well handled or they're
tolerable and it's done on the move we
established the problem we just happened
to have the tardis is left behind we
don't have the tardis um something
starts going wrong on the ship there's
something on board what do we do
first 15 minutes right up until astos
gets blasted into space at which point
pretty much everything starts to go
downhill not like an immediate nosedive
but that should have been an early
warning because astos has some of the
best interactions with the doctor just
as banter but also as like moments for
her
characterizing her because there's a
great exchange between the two of them
where she calls him out as being a bad
liar oh that liar must be difficult in
your job hey i'm an excellent liar she
well i know i didn't say that see
and it's a wonderful fast-paced rapid
shot exchange that shows again a bit
like she did with yaz in the very first
episode
reading him getting a beat on him and
just kind of
nailing down what his deal is and how at
least a certain part of his personality
functions and nailing it really quickly
and really well
and that's a good bit
i also appreciate that he is the one
person calling out the doctor on stuff
because she wants to try and you turn
the ship take it back you know and and
to get to the tardis because she's
afraid it'll be stolen which that's a
legit fear but the but ass just points
out to her like you're being hostile and
selfish there are patients on board i
need to get to mrs one as a matter of
urgency my job is to keep all of you
safe you're stopping me from doing that
he is right to call her out on that but
again it feels super telling that the
one and only character who's calling the
doctor out on stuff she should
legitimately be called out for is
ejected from space and nobody else is
gonna call the doctor on
anything definitely not in this episode
at least but his dynamic was really good
and i wish the dynamic he had with her
any of the three companions had with her
i wish any of the three of them would
confront her when she's pulling
bs because this is kind of what i meant
when i said it would have been okay if
the doctor was making mistakes that got
them all in danger and as long as
somebody is addressing that and the
characters aren't just letting it slide
and it never goes anywhere a scene like
this where asto says you are being
selfish you need to get a grip
is something that i needed now if people
really want to be super cool it'd be
like oh yeah man has to talk her down
there's no true vibe of that in this
scene somebody needed to call her out
for what she was trying to do it could
have been him it could have been anybody
it didn't have to be him it doesn't
matter but the fact that he did was a
good scene and the fact that that is
something that does not regularly happen
is what makes a lot of the stuff that
goes on with the doctor but the mistakes
she makes and the moral high horse she
has a tendency to get on become a
problem because the show never confronts
it it just does it and there's so many
great little moments like there's this
wonderful little moment between the two
of them where i'm the doctor
are you kidding sometimes
but not right now that's a great little
character response and it's the kind of
stuff i want from her more than we get
other than that as we get into the back
end look the the male pregnancy stuff
it's it's fine
it's cute it's fine it's a standard
birth oh i wasn't ready for this that
scene it's just with a guy it's like
fine whatever i do kind of appreciate
how it brings back the issue of with
ryan and his dad
and the his uh his hang ups around that
and how it evokes that they do deliver
that in another sort of hey
how do you feel about what's going on
scene which is a little bit clunky but
once yaz kind of opens the door for him
to talk about that i do i did feel that
ryan's uh explanation and his thoughts
on it felt well thought out and
legitimate
setting up him being able to talk about
it was a little clunky but
whatever oh coming back to the bating
real quick this is one of those things
along with 42
actually which i think was also chibinal
i think he wrote that
well maybe he did maybe he didn't if he
didn't i'll cut that observation but
also like with 42 i found myself asking
do we need a monster
because i'm not sure we do
like we need the scenario we need the
danger of the overall scenario
we need the complications of you know
what the other people on board are going
through
do we need a literal monster
because it's not actually adding
anything that just
the ship
heck being hit by a meteorite wouldn't
have accomplished
and it's
potentially actively detracting
so
it's it's one of those moments where the
idea of the monster of the week i think
actually hurts the story uh there's
another good sort of a little
conversation i like when uh the doctor
was sort of giving the the the medic the
assistant a little pep talk i thought
that was a decent scene it was a little
odd to me how long it took the doctor to
figure out that the potato was eating
energy actually back up what was really
odd about that is they get like this
thing this computer telling them what
the peting is and that it eats all this
stuff and it's toxic and i'm like i get
that um it it makes the point that you
know a potato on board basically means
everyone's gonna die but for the amount
of information the thing had like it
couldn't nobody had pieced together
before the doctor that it goes primarily
for energy sources and isn't just eating
the ship at random because
as she in fact does she just looks at
the pattern of what he's eating in what
order and that's what makes sense what
he's doing
so she was the first person to ever
figure that out because i would think
that would be vital information to put
put in the space wikipedia entry or
whatever it was that was read out loud
to them and it's one of those cases
where you make her smart by making the
rest of the universe dumb because that
really should have been there and again
it's that reversed it's that reverse
engineering feel
it's like well she can't figure out how
to get rid of the bating until x point
in the script so we just have to have
her figure out this thing even though
that really should have been information
that was on the space
wikipedia you know i i have a hard time
believing nobody else noticed that
pattern
uh
again it's it's feeling the hands of the
author it's it's
sensing the way in which everything was
placed artificially and the the thing is
like hand to the authors is a weird kind
of criticism in a way because
if you are attuned to writing in general
or if you do it or try to do it like you
you can become overly noticing of these
things that is true but the thing is a
well-crafted story should
make me not notice this if i'm noticing
this stuff it's because i'm not properly
absorbed by the story and so i'm
noticing these things that is part of
the problem in addition to the actual
issues being as clunky and transparent
as they are so it's a two-prong problem
uh it's a problem because of how
artificial the scenario feels and like
it feels manipulated by an author and
not a natural organic evolving situation
and then it is it's a compound problem
because if i'm noticing that not only is
it clunky and out of place but
everything else is failing to distract
me from that fact like this is one of
the reasons i don't get hung up on plot
holes because a good film
first time watching it through if you
don't notice the plot hole until either
second third fourth time or after
thinking about it really hard then the
movie did its job it wrapped you up in
the story so that you didn't notice the
plot hole while watching it for the
first time that's why i rarely go on
about plot holes unless i catch them
right off the bat now granted this is my
second viewing but i still feel like i
should not be noticing
the machinations of the author to the
degree that i am a couple of other weird
random things the doctor keeps updating
other characters on stuff that yes those
characters don't know but the audience
already does and normally you'd cover
that gap just with a time jump and just
assume the doctor explained x y and z to
characters so to have her stop and
actually do it when it's something again
that the audience already knows and has
already had explained to us and then she
then explains that again to another
character like why why would you do that
oh there's one other line i really like
oh please don't be wrong i'm so
embarrassed
and dead
that's a good line i like that line and
that's i think that's just the thing i
think this feels like an episode that
had hoped it would have a propellant
energy that would just
gloss over the issues
but it doesn't
because the issues are too numerous and
the overall construction is too clunky
to distract from the problems
but again it's not something that's
flawed in a particularly fascinating way
it's just
not polished
it's just
one or two drafts shy of being something
that should have been put in front of
cameras
saranga conundrum what do you think
about this one whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it like share subscribe
patreon
it's how i pay the bills around here
it's how we keep the whole operation up
and running and i am able to continue to
do this on the schedule that i do it
um any amount you are able to help
there's greatly appreciated don't worry
too much about it though if you can't
because
at the end of the day what i really want
you to remember is
you're beautiful
you're valid
and you're loved
you're the council
i'm just running the meetings
and then until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin lutfullah barack oliver
bean melinda walters leota boy tt for
nobulax the poodle idol tracy scrabba
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor shane ross robin moore
shayla gourlay and brendan the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]